Hello, everybody. Welcome to another holistic health hour zoom call we are going to go over the questions that were submitted and I think we're going to get to most of them. So let's jump right in and get to these questions.
And the ones that we had today were all on genetics.
Okay, so the first question since fans is highlighted, it is recommended to avoid omega six. So you have never had your genetics done with us and you're.
The you're listening to this through the detox course or something like that. You're like what in the world is this conversation about.
So your fans gene your FADS genes. This is a family of genes that we're talking about. And when we do a genetic workup, we're going to also not give you not only give you the full genetic results, but we're going to give you our summary of things to work on.
And in this case, this person had a lot of defects on their fans genes. And so therefore we highlighted that.
And one of the recommendations is to possibly avoid omega six fatty acids. Well, the fans genes have to do with digestion and absorption of nutrients.
It has to do with your digestive system. And it particularly has things to do with your digestion of fats as well.
So omega six. So let's talk about the difference between omega six, you know, Megan died, you know, mega three fatty acids, your main three different fatty acids that you're consuming.
So omega six would be founded things like flax oil. Omega six is founded fish to, but fish is going to be much higher in omega three.
Most of your seed oils are going to be very high in omega six. Well, what do we consume the most of in our diet in America? Well, omega six.
Why is olive oil a better oil to use and cooking? Well, because it's more omega nines. So omega six is not a bad oil, but we are, there's a test that you could do.
If you thought I think it's true, you know, or something like that, we're at measures, your omega three to omega six ratio. And it's a good test to run because you can really see in your body the ratio of omega three to omega six and how it could be really off.
And because you think we're eating a good diet, and yes, it's flax good for us. Sure, flax is good for us is flax oil good for us. There could be benefits to flax oil, but it's very high in omega six fatty acids.
And we tend to get way too many omega six fatty acids. So what about ground flax seeds? Well, they can have other benefits ground flax seeds also give you fiber and other benefits, but they are higher in omega six fatty acids.
So remember, first of all, rule number one, what do we look at your genes, just because you have defects, doesn't mean you have made your problems with that area, it just means that you could be prone to problems with that area.
So that's rule number one rule number two is it's all about balance. So having a lot of FADS gene defects, you might want to just consider, you know, up in your omega threes and your omega dines and decreasing your omega sixes. So it's all about balance and to understand that.
So FADS genes are dealing with fatty acids derived from triglycerides or phospholipids. These fatty acids are important fuel source, but the FAD FADS genes affect your ability to absorb and utilize those. So it may be better to increase your omega threes.
Next, next question, explain the APOE gene. I have one variant, E4, one yellow, one red, down regulated. So the APOE gene. So the APOE gene encodes for a protein that helps with the chylomicrons, your chylomicrons help carry
cholesterol and triglycerides and help you absorb cholesterol and triglycerides in your body. So that's, that's, so one of the things that APOE gene does is it helps you create those, it helps you deal with cholesterol and triglycerides in your body.
So if you have a lot of defects in your APOE genes, then you have an increase risk of not being able to control cholesterol as well. And you have an increase risk, according to multiple studies of having elevated cholesterol.
Doesn't mean you do. So again, you look at your genes. Oh, I have, let's say I have a lot of defects in my in the APOE gene, but then you do a cholesterol test. Well, my cholesterol is within normal limits. Okay, well, they don't worry about it. So again, this is your genes. It doesn't mean that it's going to equate exactly to function has so much to do with other things lifestyle diet and everything else that is tied to that.
Next, when you look at APOE genes, this is this person's genetic profile right here. Here's the APOE gene. You only have a single allele defect on one of those two genes in that family.
That gives you a negative one as far as a risk factor. So with the negative the risk factor can be negative one negative two negative three. If it was a negative three, then it would be a much higher risk factor.
So and then if you look, whatever you look at your genetic test, the full results, when you see this percentage right here, this percentage, that means out of the, there's about 70,000 people that have done this particular genetic profile out of the 70,000 people that have done this particular genetic profile, 26.3% have a single allele defect there.
But in fact, only 85% that's pretty high percent have no defect on this gene. That means 15% have some either a single allele defect on this gene.
So that's not if this was really low, this was a really rare defect to have, then this could be a higher number, even though there's only a single allele defect on one of these two genes.
This could be a negative two. If this was a rare gene to have a defect on it could cause more issues has the potential of causing more issues. So in this person's case, I don't see even looking at this gene as an important factor whatsoever.
The aisle 13 gene, the aisle 13 codes for creating aisle 13 cytokines. So cytokines are different chemicals that are made in the body that are immune communicators, they communicate to your immune system to do different things.
There's none that are bad. It's just that excess of some can be a problem. Now with single allele defects and all of these genes right here, they go, that's not good, but it still only gives us a negative one list here.
And really, it's really not an issue. It's a positive one meeting, including all the informational steps as well. So some of these aren't well studied. That's why that's the difference.
We had an informational slip and a more well studied step. So really, this is the most this top gene right here is the most important of the aisle 13 genes.
If you had a two or a one on here, it would you would give you a lower number here, but it might give you a negative one or a negative two here.
Step back a little bit. What does aisle 13 do interleukin 13 is a inflammatory cytokine in a chronic inflammatory state.
So aisle 13 is made in a B cell or a TH2 response in your body.
So in a sense, it's decreasing acute information, but it's decreasing acute immune response.
In a chronic situation, it's increasing chronic inflammation.
And you typically see people with a lot of defects in their aisle 13 that have issues with asthma that have issues with mass cell function that have a lot of skin rashes and dermatitis.
You could look up numerous studies that are very well detailed about elevated aisle 13 cytokines in acute dermatitis people that are prone to skin dermatitis issues.
So there's other issues too, not just genetics, but when we see a person that has a lot of dermatitis type issues, you want to look at their aisle 13 genes.
You also want to look at the rest of their histamine gene. So it's not just one thing. This is why it's so important to take a 30,000 elevation point of view when we're looking at your genetics is not just one gene.
And you can't say even if you had twos in here that that is the absolute cause of a person's dermatitis issues, though you could argue that it's a very strong possibility.
So this blurb that it's that stated I just took this off of the full reports so you can understand it, but I understand this is really for doctors, the aisle 13 gene encodes for immutable regulatory cytokine produce primarily by activated TH2 cells.
So this is a B cell response. So it's the it's the B cell side, the TH2 side of your immune system that stimulates and releases aisle 13 and though it can be it can decrease acute inflammation because it decreases the TH1 response.
It's it's also can it's it is still inflammatory and it can cause that inflammatory skin issues as my issues and things like that.
So this person's question is because I have these defects in my aisle 13, these single allele defects, does this mean that I am prone to asthma, I don't have any symptoms.
Yes and no, it tells you that you have the some defects that you know you may want to consider, you know, clean it up your environment.
And that's a whole idea about looking at your genetics is that it gives you clues to boy well I could be prone just based upon this could I possibly increase ability to be prone to asthma or prone to skin conditions.
And things like that possibly maybe it's just going to be the impetus for a person to help clean up their life and clean up their exposure to chemicals and things like that.
So that's how you want to look at genes it gives you clues to lifestyle changes that can improve your lifestyle because you don't want to have those issues.
I also just signed up very common with skin conditions, very common with asthma issues, very common with inflammation of the arterial wall too.
So asthma or sclerosis issues, common with aisle 13 elevation.
It seems like I have issues with detoxing.
But my pod one a GST and Cadillac was not highlighted highlighted this gives you another idea of exactly what I'm talking about maybe you don't have really any issues with your pod one genes any issues with your gluteusio genes any issues with an oxidative stress with Cadillac genes, but I seem to have issues with detoxing again pointed us back to lifestyle is everything.
So you are going to have issues with detoxing and you're going to need to support detoxing if you had if you have and had in the past a high level of exposure to different chemicals that your puts pressure on the liver and have to deal with detoxing.
So genetics is not everything genetics gives us clues to issues.
So if you had, you know, cyclopathy for 50 pond one defects a lot of gluteusio defects, so D defects and Cadillac defects, you are going to have, you know, a greater chance of having more difficulty in detoxifying, but you could have no defects in any of those genes perfectly healthy genetically detoxification pathways.
So if you're exposed to a lot more toxins than you should be exposed to that's going to cause it or look at the neurology of detoxification go back to our seven phases of detoxification book and look at the neurology of detoxification the neurology is controlled by the person that a nervous system if you're living in a very stressful environment if you have a horrible marriage if you have a horrible job situation.
Family issues, whatever you're you're not dealing with your stress very well that's going to down regulate neurologically your detoxification pathways, even if you had perfect genetics on your detoxification pathways and let's say you weren't exposed to any more toxins in the average person, which maybe that's not a good example, because the average person is exposed to way too much toxic toxins, but let's say you were exposed to less.
But now your detoxification pathways are only 50% because you're in sympathetic overdrive and your parasympathetic nervous system is suppressed well that can be a cause of things too that's why you want to look at your body as holistically as possible it's why i'm so big and looking at your genetics, but you can't only look at your genetics hey i'm big until let's do some some tests on toxicity profiles, but you can't only look at that i'm big and look at let's look at blood work let's look at.
But this, but you can't only look at that you have to look at as many different pictures of your health as possible and i'll tell you right out lifestyle change and lifestyle modification is the key to overcoming all of this.
All right well thanks so much for another holistic health arm, make sure you get your questions asked we'll be back in two weeks and answering more of your questions bye bye.